so mike what is the status of your
relationship today
um we were able to work it out
and today we're back together
wow yeah
thank you way to go mike
is somebody clapping
wow yeah
thank you way to go mike
with pride mike announces he and ximena
got back together i'm done
after she told him she didn't want
anything to do with him following their
breakup
we'll get into how he used that good old
cha-ching cha-ching to make it happen
plus i have discovered
uh that gino prefers to masturbate
rather than making love to me jasmine
reveals she and geno only slept together
once when he was visiting her for a
month in panama
wow
and finally kim breaks down in tears and
walks off set after she finds out usman
reached back out to his ex zara after
she left tanzania
let's talk about it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia
as you can see i am back in studio and
our show has a name
90 day replay we got us a cute little
graphic
we are just
also i love how you all have created
such a strong community in the comments
some of you are hilarious like mikko who
said quote mike tried to buy ximena now
he wants a refund anything i paid for i
want to take back with me to new york
that was a good one there are also some
valid points being made sanet said quote
ximena knows how to survive her whole
life is based on survive
some people are raised on love some on
survival
wow santa that was deep
[Music]
speaking of survival let's get into the
life-altering choice ximena was faced
with during the season finale then we'll
get into the tell-all they both air at
the same night this only reinforces the
fact that you were using me for money
after ximena ended things with mike and
told him over and over again to leave
her house i have proof that i pay the
rent in this house so i'm not leaving he
finally agrees to spend his last night
in colombia in a hotel
this not only brings him to tears but he
met his mom and sister as well
[Music]
[Music]
wow
she's got that love and respect for mike
because he's kept her family afloat
also i love how although ximena's mom is
sad that they won't be getting mike's
financial help anymore she's still
supportive of her daughter's choice in
the relationship because let's be real
in a case like this some parents would
not put their child's happiness first
[Music]
it all boils down so she just doesn't
like him i want to pull up a comment
from heather who makes an interesting
point about ximena ending her
relationship with mike
she says quote i do believe mike lured
her in with money but i believe she
honestly tried to see if there was
something there
there was not i agree i think that there
was a time where ximena figured hey why
not he's been providing security for me
he thinks the world of me
i should want to marry him right
obviously it's not that simple if it's
not there
it's not there
on the day mike is leaving for america
ximena decides not to allow him to say
goodbye to her sons and the rest of her
family in person this is a big loss for
me because i've
grown attached to harold and juan
and
i deserve better
than just saying goodbye over the phone
[Music]
it really feels like crap
but i'm really just ready to
just go home and just
move on with
my life
well i guess he changed his mind once he
got to new york because from the looks
of what happens next it doesn't even
seem as if he tried to move on my essay
the day after mike leaves colombia he
reaches back out to ximena
while she just so happens to be talking
to the cameras
and he tells her he wants to pay her
rent
use me
and get married when he returns to
columbia
no
[Music]
in colombia
okay
mike just gave off one of those sketchy
used car salesman smirks
foreign
[Music]
is it
just like a number of you have pointed
out in the comments there are women who
are faced with this decision all the
time
do i choose being taken care of or do i
choose my happiness
in ximena's case she also has to think
about how mike's help will benefit her
sons her mom her sister her entire
family
what would you do be real
and don't look at me because i'll be
honest i don't know what i would do
it sounds good in theory to say no i
wouldn't accept his help
i'm gonna get out here and make it
happen
but that takes time and if i was to look
around and see my loved ones struggling
in the moment
i couldn't imagine choosing my happiness
over them having what they need
that's a tough one
yeah well based off part one of the
tell-all it sounds like ximena ends up
taking one for the team so mike what is
the status of your relationship today
um we were able to work it out
and today we're back together
wow yeah
thank you way to go mike i don't know
why whoever clapped clapped and i don't
know why gino is acting as if someone is
truly winning here
at least kim kept it real in the moment
today we're back together
wow yeah
mike is probably holding on so tight to
this relationship because he thinks he
would never get another woman who looks
like ximena again but the love you can
buy mike is not the love you want
[Music]
pick up here come on wake up while mike
is in the clouds next week ximena
reveals that things are not all rosy
when she starts talking also mike's
friend and 90 day mvp neesee
joins the tell-all
amena are you back together
isn't that crazy oh my god oh no she
just admitted it wow oh god
[Music]
i have nothing else left to say
all right let's quickly touch on jasmine
dishing some shocking information about
her sex life with geno
when gino traveled to panama he brought
along some blue pills
it all started when the topic of geno's
blue pills came up remember those
these are the little blue pills
well while gino says he ended up not
having to use them that conversation led
to this never before seen clip
we were gonna have sex this morning
so i went to the gym and i asked him to
wait for me but when i
came back from the gym you know was like
avoiding me and i was like why baby what
happened and then he told me that well
baby because i was playing with my
peepee
[Music]
playing with the peepee without me to me
it is
it was more because
we had such a busy day planned after
that clip plays jasmine reveals she and
gino only had sex one time while he
visited her for a month in panama it was
definitely more than once definitely
worth at the resort we did it once and
it was so good she says he preferred
pleasuring himself rather than getting
intimate with her particularly for a man
you need to drain your freaking balls
one way or the other
if you are not the one draining your
balls who is it
this conversation leads to jasmine
begging geno for more sex in front of
everyone why you punish me with sex if
you know that i am love
with you is so freaking good i love it
dino i love it i'm vegan but i want your
freaking meat give me the meat i want it
you know i'm terrified i shouldn't be
begging a man for sex i can't tell if
she's serious or not his own sexiness is
what make him sexy for me i like that
i love it
gino says that part of him not wanting
to have sex with jasmine was that they
argued a lot and i still can't make
sense of it we also learned that these
two met through a sugar baby website
we met on
believe it or not
a sugar baby site but during the season
jasmine said this and if i'm on a daily
sugar diet if that's gonna be my
business which i'm not interested in
look at me
and i'm intelligent
i will get a sugar daddy that is the
sugar daddy of the sugar daddies not a
crazy old man lon and depressing from
michigan give me a break
the irony what is up with the lies
according to jasmine her best friend put
her on the website and she initially
didn't know what it was uh-huh
right
okay last but not least usman and kim
during the season finale after she left
tanzania usman goes and calls his ex
zara
and starts flirting with her
mind you kim knew nothing about this
until the day of the tell-all and her
son jamal is on set while she watches
the clip for the first time
oh no
hi zara how are you oh you called her
if i should ask you do you miss anything
about me
[Music]
i miss you wow are you sure about that
wow this is humiliating yeah i'm
positive
you're the first lady in my life that
you know she's sticking my head all the
time
you know why this is disrespectful well
one of the reasons why it's
disrespectful
is because he knew that one day this
footage was going to be available for
kim and the world to see
and he didn't even have the decency to
tell her before the tell-all
zara was such a huge part of their
storyline he had to know producers would
bring that conversation up he didn't
care though if we are to be back
together like from
here i don't know
am i going to get that real love i had
before now
i can't offer anyone fake club
i know if you sound crazy and you may
not believe it all of you
i will never cheat
osman that was a waste of a sentence
kim tells sean she needs a minute and
walks off set i need a minute
can you hear me
why are you clapping at her like that
oh no that's right jamal stand up for
your mama
kym valley
i will tell you what happened
hold the hold on hold on hold on
somebody
useman seems like he will not appreciate
kim until she's out of his life and next
week it looks like she's going to
struggle with making that decision
mom after everything i did
to call zara there's a slap in my face
we're like what do i do now do i make it
work now
nope
if only it was that simple in this
90-day world all right fans fam make
sure you stick with et because we are
covering it all i will see you next time